at the bitcoin conference jack dorsey
uh spoke i think i believe he said uh
bitcoin changes everything
i think he made a video for jack trying
to
explain different ideas to him uh i
guess describing the difference between
proof of work and proof of stake as
we've talked about
right what do you hope jack dorsey comes
to understand about the difference
between
proof of work and proof of stake well i
hope he understands it's just a resource
that's the entire point of the video i
was trying to make is like
dude you're like in this cult where you
think the only way to be secure is proof
of work and somehow proof of stake is
less secure than proof of work
i don't even know how you you put those
inequalities there because you're
talking about apples and oranges
you're making different trade-offs and
there's different assumptions about the
nature of the people involved
but the mechanics are the same and so
it's really more of a question of
what type of system do you prefer do you
want mercenaries guarding rome or do you
want roman citizens garmin
rome okay and as the romans learn it's
better to have citizens usually doing
that
okay and that's the only point i was
trying to make to uh to dorsey and you
know
i don't think he watched it or
particularly cared uh but
it was more of a video for everyone and
to start that dialogue of realizing that
the real game is not is proof of stake
better than proof of work
it's how do we go from one to n and what
should n be
you just mentioned that semantical
addressable web going back to ipfs and
these other concepts
well what how do you pay for the
enormous burden of storing that much
data
you can create a consensus protocol for
it there actually is one it's called
permacoin
came out 2014-15 andrew miller wrote it
and a few other authors i think are um
john katz may have been an author as
well
but basically it's just a you know a
throwaway proof-of-work style algorithm
that only works if you have large
amounts of data
okay so it's like your minor is like a
hard drive
effectively mm-hmm proof of storage i
think you call this yeah
this type of stuff and there's been
since then many iterations evolutions of
that type of protocol
okay so what if you throw that into your
resource back
now you have a capacity in your system
for storing
huge amounts of information that's
incentivized by the way the system works
and you can balance that with a proof of
stake system and you can balance that
with uh
let's say you have proof of useful
computation we may have a paper on that
who knows
coming soon uh and what if you have a
proof of useful computation where maybe
you can do walkstat or something who
knows
uh with something like that okay well
now you have three resources inside your
system
and those three things keep your system
secure they keep each other balanced and
they just so
happen to create the world's largest
supercomputer that's programmable and it
just so happens to create the world's
largest database that's programmable
in addition to having a shareholder
style model for ownership inside of it
to kind of balance these things out so
people care about the appreciation of
value
inside the system so that was my point
to jack is your business guy
why are you betting all your eggs and
one crazy model that's a cult
step away and realize that that does
something it's a tool but saws
aren't the only tool in the toolbox
there's hammers and screwdrivers and
other things
go to end resources and let's have a
real conversation about
what would a world computer or world
infrastructure that's useful for your
business domain in his case twitter
require and what type of resources would
you need for the such a thing well in
this case
square more importantly currently if you
look at squaring cash app they support
uh bitcoin you know he is kind of all in
on the proof of work
idea not all in but currently kind of uh
that's the
the one supported i guess i did just a
tip and proof of work
i love you so much charles thank you
appreciate this
but uh i'm not gonna run with that even
though i'm tempted to
uh but uh looking forward do you hope
cardano
becomes part of cash app i i mean he's a
business guy or at least i'd hope he is
and
it's not about what i want or what he
wants it's about what markets want
you know when you run a publicly traded
company your fiduciary obligation your
shareholders to maximize the
utility of the sustainability and value
of your company
uh and so if he's running in a company
that makes money off of these things it
makes absolutely no sense to be a
maximalist
you want transaction volume that's how
you make your damn money it was coinbase
was the same way they were very
maximalist in the beginning
very quickly they started realizing hey
we're losing a lot of money if we want
to ipo we kind of need to
be a bit more diverse eric voorhees was
also a maximalist way back today now
look at eric he's got shape shift and
all these other pieces of infrastructure
he's a lot more friendly with us
ultis so you know jack will make that
decision his people will make that
decision i think based on market
dynamics transaction volume and
value to the user and if the concern is
actually legitimately security then
the only question i'd ask their team is
can you please provide me a definition
of one
doing pow is more secure than
proof of stake as a tweet isn't is not
really a proof okay you need to actually
come out and sit down and say what is
your security model what do you care
about
what do you value what's the problems
you're concerned about proof of stake
and they never really get there and
that's why i call you know this maximum
like a religion
because it's just like saying you know
the angels descended from the heavens
and it's like well how do you know well
because the bible said so or this
doctrine said so it's like well that's
your evidence somebody wrote something
down
dude can you please give me a little bit
more they say no you're challenging the
word of god
in this case you're challenging the word
of satoshi and all i ask for is just
what does the burden of proof we wrote
the papers we have security models we
went through the peer review process
god that was not easy we wrote formal
specifications in some cases we
formalized those specifications with
isabel for god's sakes which is not easy
to do
and then we implemented it and it's
running in production with a million
users at a 50 billion dollar market cap
i mean it's what point does you do you
start saying well maybe there's
something there
you know and they say no there's nothing
there and it's not secure it can't be
secure
it's okay then why do you believe what
you believe and they never come back to
me with an answer
ever why i believe god didn't go through
a peer review process when he wrote the
ten commandments so
um sometimes it works out sometimes not
you